hold on we got to do the thing where I'm
a surprise guest all right
thought that would be actually a good
intro just use all of it good morning
John good morning hey we're at VidCon
room Adobe are you gonna become one of
those people who like where's your
sponsors all the time and you're like I
want to shout out Oakley's while I'm
here and also thanks to dr. pepper for
providing me with that key hydration
hashtag win at hashtag any cost
hashtag invest in your digestion hashtag
Metamucil I actually didn't bring Mike
Metamucil and it's already the problem
don't move I'm not going to never move
again they won't let me open this all
right let's go cuz that kid peed off the
balcony at VidCon 2016 and now they
closed all the balconies that is such a
great metaphor by the way for the
Internet one person piece of about doing
nobody else gets a balcony ever again so
I asked people to send us questions
about our past and future on YouTube
Kathy asks why did you stop making
straight-up silly videos I think what
happened is that I felt like the rest of
the internet got pretty good at being
silly right but it wasn't as good at
being earnest and I was like oh like I'm
quite earnest of everything you've
created Blake asks what piece of content
are you most proud of
oh definitely that tumblr post where it
has me jumpin against the wall to prove
that I'm not an octopus
it may be your most viewed piece of
media John if death is a cube does that
mean you have to meet the face of death
six different times if death is a marble
will it win a marble race me not you
look very cool thinking of marbles how
did the green dots do in the marble in
pix
I haven't had the chance to watch you I
don't wanna spoil this for you like go
green ducts
chillon says when you guys retire I
imagine your education channels will
continue but will you let vlogbrothers
die or is bloggers there something you
will continue until you are physically
unable well thanks for that I want to
choose to end the channel you want to
upload all your last video and know it's
your last video instead of just yes it's
interesting to think about like why are
we still doing this it's been a really
long time it has been over a third of my
life Wow and you're old I liked our job
like I like I like the people I work
with I like making educational video my
look
supercool and your adobe hashtag create
your story sunglasses do I actually look
cool I don't think I look at that good
well one thing I got to take off this
sticker well you know like obviously we
haven't done it for money for a long
time so there are other reasons we are
making stuff and the main reason is the
main reason we were making stuff in 2007
when there also wasn't any money
involved which is that we like making
stuff with people we like and we like
each other and we really like the
community of nerdfighteria yeah
sorry that was overly sincere can you go
get me the dab don't dab on camera don't
worry once endo dabs own hashtag no dab
zone pecan pancakes wants us to do
another year of brotherhood 2.0 style
vlog maybe the last year that we do it
oh that's a good idea
I'd be so hard from your style I think I
would either go inspire the other thing
is that it's really good for my mental
health to have the anchor of a Tuesday
aside from everything else there's also
that now I don't want to quit let's not
quit why would we quit stop talking
about quitting it's we're eating says I
just ate dinner that's great
you two could switch personalities and
lives would you wire no no no I like my
kids thanks kid but not as much as I
like my kids our lift driver just asked
us if you were going to see that Chuck
green thing I mean I'm really honored if
people still associate VidCon with Chuck
green I was jealous of your eyewear so
I'm putting on my cinnamon toast crunch
the sleep man I'm gonna put on this
fanny pack these are socks I can't see
anything
where's the fanny pack I look like the
worst blues brother I thought it was a
blanket it's a cinnamon toast crunch
bathroom how did you get this and I
didn't get it I'm super annoyed what
what Hank I'll see you on Tuesday
hashtag win at hashtag all costs avoid
the tab